c'est de la glace quand vous montre là
beaucoup de glacée où sommes-nous on est
en Antarctique on est à 600 mètres
sous un immense glacier qui reste une
source d'inquiétude pour les chercheurs
on a même déployé des robots pour
travailler tout là alors Renaud est là
pour nous en parler on voulait que vous
nous parliez de la fonte des glaces des
problèmes de patinoire des problèmes sur
Canal Guido mais là vous y allez pas
être le dos de la cuillère avait fallu
de glacier on est en bas partie alors on
parle de quelle glacier avec un
gigantesque glacier c'est le glacier
tweight donc ça c'est un glacier qui est
grand comme la Floride donc vous les
gros on vous donne gros il se trouve
dans l'ouest de l'Antarctique et c'est
un glacier qu'on le voit sur la carte en
ce moment c'est ce qui est en rouge et
c'est un glacier qui est mal en point en
ce moment on estime que ça fonte jusqu'à
maintenant a été responsable de 4% de la
hausse de tout le niveau de la mer
depuis les 150 dernières années donc à
lui seul et si venait à fondre au
complet il ferait monter le niveau de la
mer de 1 m donc ça gigantesques ça
risque de se produire mais on sait pas
exactement quelle vitesse ça va arriver
les chercheurs restent comprendre
pourquoi et c'est pour ça qu'il y a des
projets de recherche et un des plus
importants qu'on a en ce moment c'est le
projet melt où on envoie justement des
robots pour essayer de comprendre un peu
qu'est-ce qui se passe au sous le
glacier et ça c'est un élément très
important pour essayer de comprendre
cette fonte là parce que il y a une
partie du glacier qui flotte à la
surface de l'océan que l'autre est
attachée attachée à la terre ferme puis
le point qu'on entre les deux qu'on le
voit sur les matchs en ce moment c'est
ce qu'on appelle la ligne d'ancrage et
plus cette ligne là elle est loin dans
les terres moins glacée stable et pour
ce qui est du glacier tweight cette
ligne là le reculer de 14 km depuis 1990
mais pour comprendre comment le glacier
les gruger part en dessous comme ça ben
faut aller voir avec des robots alors
c'est à ça que ça sert les robots parce
que pas personne qui va aller là lié en
langue grenouille à 1800 pieds là 600
mètres et demi effectivement on envoie
personne là et donc pour y aller les
chercheurs en forêt un trou de 600
mètres ils ont des descendu un robot
jusqu'au niveau juste au niveau de la
marque en dessous un robot qui s'appelle
ice fine un peu comme un long cylindre
et ce boulot est allé prendre des des
données sur les propriétés de l'eau ils
ont laissé des instruments de mesure ils
ont publié les chercheurs les données de
ces mesures-là dans Nature la semaine
dernière il y a du positif et du négatif
dans ce cas observé côté positif le
glacier semble fondre plus lentement que
prévu ça c'est parce que il y a une
mince couche d'eau très froide qui
s'accumule à la frontière entre le
glacier et l'eau de mer un peu plus
chaude qui sert un peu d'isolant donc ça
ralentit la fonte des glaces par contre
aux endroits où il y a des fissures qui
se sont formés dans le glacier ce
phénomène-là arrête le l'eau chaude
l'eau plus chaude s'engouffre ça vient
creuser les fissures six fois plus vite
que ça le fait le reste du glacier et ça
ben ça peut venir le déstabiliser donc
on a cette balance lente et deux
phénomènes on sait pas encore exactement
à quelle vitesse ça va progresser mais
c'est ce genre d'études-là qui va nous
donner l'information manquante
fantastique Antarctique tout ce qu'on
peut faire l'autre comme recherche non
mais c'est vrai il y a des expéditions
sportives exceptionnelles mais il y a de
la science également bon je vous amène
plus proche de chez nous dans les Grands
Lacs je faisais allusion canal Rideau
puis d'autres endroits d'autres plan
d'eau qui ont pas gelé il y a moins de
glace aussi cette année je mens même si
ça a gelé dans les Grands Lacs
effectivement on va voir une image à
l'écran qui était prise le 13 février
dernier ça c'est nos grands lacs qui ont
été pris par un satellite de l'agence
américaine d'observation
océanique atmosphérique à nous montre
que les Grands Lacs le 13 février était
presque entièrement libre de glace la
couverture était seulement de 6.6% de
glace alors que d'habitude pour février
la couverture glaciaire elle est entre
30 et 40%. ça c'est la plus faible
couverture de glace pour un 13 février
depuis qu'on a commencé à prendre des
données satellites et comme on va le
voir sur un graphique dans quelques
instants mais c'est certain qu'on peut
pas prendre une une année unique pour
dire que la situation est anormale mais
depuis 1973 la moyenne de glace sur les
Grands Lacs en hiver elle a baissé de
69%. donc moins en moins de glace
d'année en année sur les Grands Lacs
c'est sûr que le record de cette année
et causer entre autres principalement
par des variabilités climatiques qu'on a
au dessus de l'océan Atlantique et
au-dessus de l'océan Pacifique à une
énorme influence sur les Grands Lacs en
tant que tel mais sur cette grande
tendance là qu'on voit qu'il baisse d'un
an année c'est sûr que la crise
climatique a un énorme rôle à jouer et
c'est ce qui fait qu'on peut avoir des
images un peu déprimantes comme celle-là
oui puis ça peut changer toute la lune
de la navigation également il y a du
commerce qui se fait la marine marchande
bien évidemment navigation les
écosystèmes
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI